every company needs to check you know to
make an insight work
and to understand how to make uh the
company more inclusive
and you know it's
before you're trying to to recruit
diverse employees you need to
understand
how your
employees feel
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders meet
shakhar silis the managing director of
power in diversity
chaka is the managing director of power
and diversity an initiative founded by a
group of leading vcs to promote
diversity and inclusion in the startup
ecosystem her previous roles include
managing the 9900 alumni association and
working as a process engineer in the
semiconductor industry
chakra holds a bachelor's degree in
chemical engineering from the technion
israel institute of technology as well
as a certification and strategy
consultant
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
so much for joining me how are you
i'm great thank you for having me hey
thank you very much i'm always looking
forward to these types of conversations
talking about the ecosystem you know in
general and trying to understand you
know what's happening where where are we
aiming to get to
you know you you've been involved with
communities for quite some time and
today you're running a diversity and
inclusion community working with i
believe more than 40 vcs and over 120
startups and from the israeli ecosystem
you know trying to piece together at
least in these 20 minutes you know what
is diversity and inclusion from your
perspective and how are we doing in the
israel ecosystem and where where are we
heading what needs to be done so welcome
welcome to the show
thank you i'm excited to be here so tell
me tell me a little bit about your
background and how you ended up finding
yourself in diversity and inclusion
okay so i i'm actually coming from a
very different world
and in my position i'm a chemical
engineer right
yeah
so
i
but back back at the beginning i was
born in haifa and i served in a unit
called 9900
in the intelligence first
and i started studying chemical
engineering at the technion
and was very excited about the thing
that i can you know dealing with so many
fields under the same roof i have you
know
i had my
research in the semiconductors field and
i worked as a rnd student in a chemical
factory and my final project was
in in the field of green energy
so uh
i you know i had a chance to taste a bit
from anything
under this title
and when i finished my studying i
started working as a process engineer
with intel and after two fascinating
years i realized that i need to do
something that you know
make me be more satisfied and make an
influence and make an impact and
working with people
and
i started studying
started the consulting and one thing led
to another and today
i'm leading empowering diversity
initiative
and i am lucky you know to collaborate
with
an amazing disease you said the
uh 40 this is i think today we are
spending on more than 60 and more than
startups
so
the numbers are amazing but
the most important thing is that we can
see an actual actual change
in our work
and
that's it this is how i get to
to this point
how do you define
diversity and inclusion
specifically pertaining also to the
israeli ecosystem
so first of all i think that the israeli
ecosystem is very unique and it's very
you know innovation it's all about
innovation
and
we have a lot of groups in the ecosystem
that unfortunately um are you know
underwear represents and
don't get an equal
chance
to involve the itec sector
and for me and i think it's it's not
just for me it's for power university in
general
and the most thing the most important
thing is the fact that diversity for me
is not something related to to charity
or to doing you know a good deed it's
something that in the israeli ecosystem
has the power to
to to change the
development of the company
it can make companies much more you know
profitable and to perform better uh
financial results and it's increased you
know the the the creativity of the
company and it makes companies to
to be much more open-minded and and
inclusive to the environment in general
and i think that
we have a massive potential of
combining all those groups you know when
i'm saying a underrepresented
a group i'm talking about
people from the arab sector and
people
with disabilities and people from the
champion community and and the rank is
so wise but
basically we're talking about everyone
that doesn't get you know the
opportunity for the same opportunity and
to get into this world
and i think that you know if you get
into a
startup company you know in tel aviv
you will probably see
that the employees look
kind of you know the same and their
background is very
similar
and
something you know about today
i think we can see a global
change in this field of diversity and
inclusion but in israel i think that the
fact that we are you know
always in you know
always trying to be
a
you know very innovative and trying to
do things differently
so
there is no reason we will stay behind
in the in the
in this world in the diversity and
improve themselves so
why why did there become a need for an
organization to bring together
all of these venture capital funds and
startups to
work on diversity inclusion
so what what was sort of the pain point
that this community is solving
so first of all i will tell you how
everything
was started and power university was
started was established by alan feld
from vintage partners
and alan joined for a
other visitors pitango viola
capital and gilot capital
they are both cultures of the initiative
and i think the need was
the fact that we need to
you know use the power the investors uh
have
uh especially because you know when
you're
trying to decide you know the vcs are
the fuel behind the industry they are
eventually
the one that gets the decision
of which product will change your life
and what will be you know the
next unicorn so i think the value of of
getting involved
and this fails also i mean to make a
change and see
how they they can join the effort and
how they can
you know
explain their portfolio companies this
issue is very
you know
important
and this is something that we are using
in in the initiative
but also i think that this is
as the option
uh
to
to you know they are
the best
people to know their portfolio company
so they can
work with us we we are working with a
social psychologist we're working with
diversity experts
and
i think that all those
factors together
uh can make an actual change
and
we we can see the results in the field
you know we're working with an amazing
companies and we can see their
statistics and
you know even starting a process in a
company
and you know
publishing
the process to their employees
uh makes a change
it's you know a change in the state of
mind it's it's it's the fact that you
care
and we can see the influence
from the beginning
and
we are very pleased with it with the
results is there a way to quantify the
success of an organization like this or
quantifying some
measurable way the the impact that an
organization like this is having on on
an ecosystem
sure so for us it's all about you know
measurements we we believe in numbers
and we are also working right now and
developing a benchmark that will set a
standard for the industry and will help
companies to understand where they are
standing
compared to their contestants but
we measure everything we do when we work
with a company first of all we're doing
a first evaluation
and trying to
to to realize where the company stands
in the current situation and then to
uh
make sure we are activate the the needs
of the company and
then you know the process of getting and
accomplish their purpose is much more
easier and we are of course measuring in
things after the process the six months
after and a year after
and how do you actually go about making
taking those measurements is that simply
by talking to them is that is it
standardized in some way well what have
you learned about you know gathering
together these pieces of information
that you know don't seem to too trivial
to standardize and normalize
so it's a mix of things but i think that
festival is the fact that we are
interviewing uh employees
you know
you don't need to be a manager or a vp
you know a
r d in order to to to count
so we asked
the employees
how they fell and everything is
anonymous so they saw very comfortable
with sharing with us
and
we are doing a survey and
you know
one at the beginning and one in the
middle and then the end of the process
and the things we
realize with first of all that
there is something
in the fact that the company is getting
into the process and you know we
encourage companies to to share and
spread the word and not just to the
press but also you know to to their
employees and there is something that
makes the
employees feel much more comfortable to
to share things to share their uh your
feelings
and
you can learn so many things when your
employees feel you know comfortable to
share
and this is one thing and
and also we have
we compare we have a baseline
of the industry so we can compare it to
other companies
and
we are trying
to do you know
uh
the best with you know analyzing
everything we are using the best experts
in the industry in order uh to
to to use the tools we have it's i mean
we've done this for almost five years
and we are constantly learning you know
every
company is different
and
we are just i mean in the beginning we
worked only with the companies that over
employees
and
the the reason was because we thought
you know we we heard a lot about the you
know startups in the beginning of their
way can deal with diversity this is just
fun
so
i'm happy to share that i got it i mean
i
have a lot more
a you know start up small startups that
wants you know to
to understand how to do a
diversity
actions better
and
you know what we we try to put a spot on
the companies even the small companies
or the companies that do do this
this works good in a good way
and to to spread the word and to show
ceo that it's possible
and you
you know you you just need to use the
the right tools
and we are here to to help them
and we are making everything much more
accessible so
if you had to
you know pinpoint you know one or two of
the most critical
um aspects in today's israeli ecosystem
that we should pay attention to when it
comes to diversity and inclusion
something very tangible and specific
that that really is something that we
need to address and and something that
we could address
well what should our focus be what what
what is what are those things that we
should really be focusing on
so i think that
first of all we need to focus on the
fact that every every company needs to
check you know to make an insight work
and to understand how to make a the
company more inclusive
and you know if
before you are trying to to recruit
diverse employees you need to
understand
how your
employees feels about you know having a
ready person to
to work a sidearm or
you know
doing a a
a group trip to uh
you know with with with haribeen
or people from the arabic sectors and
you know adjust the activities you're
doing
and that will be
more inclusive
because
i can tell you that we when we
made a survey in one of our companies we
find out that
there are employees that are not very
open or
i would say afraid
from you know working with people that
are different from them really and yeah
wow yeah and it's super interesting as
i don't think i mean
at the beginning of the process when you
ask employers if they will be okay with
the possibility of working with some
someone that is
very different from from them
they will say you know it's anonymous so
they can say
they will feel uncomfortable with this
or something similar
but at the end of the process after you
doing a lot of effort and
and it's a lot of effort
and
of explaining
uh
why it's not so frightening you know to
work with with with different people and
why why what is good not just for the
company it's good for you and
as you know
a
person
and
uh you get you you open your mind uh
for this and i think this is the
the thing that i personally uh
most uh i mean love in the process yeah
the fact that you can see the change you
can see that the individual
person change his mind and you know
understand
the process of
getting amazing being more inclusive
looking at yourself you know as a leader
of this community and
you know day in and day out working on
this where do you get the most
satisfaction what are the moments that
you know leave you because obviously
you're working on something that is very
high impact it is something for the
community for the ecosystem something
that i think everybody can agree on is
important and and will serve for the
benefit of both people especially people
of that that that are going to be
included in this diversity and inclusion
and but but generally for the for the
tech ecosystem so what you know which
part of it really satisfies you on on a
day-to-day basis
well first of all to see a ceo you know
that said that they are doing the best
they can that there is nothing else to
do and you know the reason they don't
have enough women is because there
aren't enough women in the industry and
then making a
a process in the company and you know
showing the opposite so i think the
satisfaction there is is huge
and
we are working uh
really to
to
i won't say educate but to
to to show companies that there is
another way
and to show a how valuable this thing
and when i hear a you know a ceo that
tells me that
he we put
an employee that is
on the autistic spectrum and is his best
employee i mean it's
i mean it's it's way beyond the above
the expectations
so
i think
those things are the most say you know
inspiring for me what was this also
always a you know a passion or
motivation of yours
to work on a diversity inclusion was
this always something that that you know
you there was that was bothering you or
that you found potential in even before
that while you were at intel and and in
the military and and later on in 19800
well i i think so i think first of all i
was lucky uh as an engineer in intel i
worked with you know people from the
arab sector and we'd say
and my manager was a woman and
i think the the
the environment i worked at was very
diverse
but
a
actor and when i you know
moved on and even
in the army and you know in a lot of
in engineering studying maybe not in
chemical engineering but but when when
i've done all the you know math or
electrical studies
at my degree i saw
a gap and you know i i saw the gap i saw
that there is a difference between
the amount of a a
student already
it doesn't matter if it's you know
women or people with disability which is
a strong thing that was always
important to me
and i think that the
the
the workplace or the tech sector is
you know
the one environment that their
limitations are easy to break
you know i think that in the army is
maybe
harder
and
in schools we had a lot to work to to we
have a lot of work to do there also but
but it's a process and i think that when
we are talking about the tech sector
especially because
uh things moving fast especially in
startups you know and and as
if your your crew is more you know
diverse
so you can be much more i mean you can
you can be more flexible you can
treat yourself with chains and
and and you know we we saw things with
covet we saw how important it is so
i do think that the value for the tech
sector is it's really much more than
than
you know
do good for the society
so so yeah personally i want to see much
more
i want to see different people when i
enter to a startup company
and hopefully you know the tech sector
will set an example for the rest of the
industry
this was wonderful and inspiring and
thank you for all the great work that
you're doing for our ecosystem
and thank you for you know for sharing
with me your perspective and your story
and the founding story of this community
and and it really is a you know warming
my heart that there are so many of the
incredible vcs and startups in israel
that are working hard to to promote
diversity and inclusion not just in
their own companies but in the community
and the ecosystem in general so thank
you very much for your hard work and
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you
[Music]